oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
now I've calmed down since the last time
that I played this and it's going to go
much better
number one full disclosure I started a
new a new thing with a Super Mario maker
so I'm actually on a new hundred mario
challenge and the reason I did that is
because of the just pure douchiness of
the last one well what am I supposed to
do with you Bob I forgot about it okay
so this level is called small to big and
it has to do with like big world small
world like such a bad start okay this
has to do like small the big world you
know like in mario 64 that that cool
love Jake it's okay chicas we're
wandering around all worried I'm just
trying to be cool I'm just trying to be
cool okay so from now on no more of just
trying to live chica it's okay I'm just
I'm just trying to live I'm just trying
to live chicas putting her head in my
lap right now it's okay chica I'm just
trying I'm just trying to live okay so
now we're gonna go about this calmly and
collectively and we're going to be 100%
100% because we are cool individuals who
go into things calmly and collectively
without any panic and anything that we
do
oh god oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh
oh gosh
well fogers vulgaris oh who are you okay
okay everything's fine I think I did the
right move there oh man oh man oh wow
okay but I'm doing wonderfully I'm doing
phenomenally what do I don't lie to me
okay you didn't lie to me did you yes
okay I am going to fly through these
expert levels I'm going to do this
better than you guys have ever seen
Mario maker done even though just a
little bit like few minutes ago you saw
it be done badly like the worst you've
ever seen and admittedly that's bad but
now I'm going to get through this
eh okay because I am good at what I do
and so long as doesn't throw what is
happening okay all right here we go
business and sanity what am I supposed
to be doing here is there an answer to
this Oh God why go off here oh okay
can I get away from the madness nope
okay well how do you Oh guys I'm not
supposed to be down there I'm not
supposed to be down here I'm not
supposed to be okay okay okay okay okay
restart something horribly wrong
what the hell happened okay so obviously
I'm not supposed to I supposed to go
that way
supposed to go let's both Zeus jump
there we go got him good okay I'm gonna
go through the door now cuz I don't know
what else I'm doing with my hello hi
how's it going everybody won't just
wander through don't mind me okay
what the [ __ ] is happening here
okay okay all right then
can I just oh I can just grab it I
didn't know that all right then
no okay you know what this this one's a
madhouse hello hi what am i doing what's
happening
I don't understand it okay goodbye
goodbye world
god damn it why do I have to get all the
weird levels what the hell happened to
this what happened to fun normal good
old-fashioned levels where wow there was
a star there that's how I got that okay
well [ __ ] [ __ ] god damn it well alright
then you know okay I'm okay let's just
go let's try this again hello hi buddies
pop okay so that's how I got that and
that's goodbye okay now I got this
goodbye to you all right cool goodbye to
you goodbye to you it's gonna get out
well that's that looks good why did you
get evil when you add a spin jump in you
know no there we go thank you take the
evil away from you the evil out of your
soul ha boink okay so if I can just make
my way downtown walking fast moving
passing them homebound over this way
push it push it push it come on dude oh
I can't oh okay I need that okay so I
just need to get out of there in time
before it's all kerfuffled her [ __ ]
ated
the technical term
okay thank you hmm goosal to south okay
HAP there we go okay I'm out of here
baby I'm out of here
let me take care of you guys you
[ __ ] first ah [ __ ] your nut
okay now I'm short enough we are doing
wonderfully we're a blazer I'm out of
water all right cool he's so sad but at
least were alive that's all the matter I
almost broke the record with my slow ass
I almost broke the record on that
sumbitch on to level three that was only
two holy [ __ ] I forgot I skipped one god
damn it I need to calm down
is this [ __ ] was I not supposed to do
that
seems like something I was supposed to
do I mean just just saying it kind of
you don't need to be laughing at me when
I'm doing the right thing how about if I
go over it what's gonna happen if I do
that this is gonna be a bad is this
gonna be bad for me this is gonna be bad
who's gonna bet it's not gonna work is
it it's not gonna work it's a big ball
it worked
ha ha ha did I get the right one on the
first try my fingers going oh my god oh
no
okay oh okay okay okay
everything's fine this is going
beautifully okay
spikes and Falls I don't like the sound
of that because I've got horrible
horrible horrible memories of spikes
don't even do nothing to me
am I supposed to get around you am I
supposed to pop into one of you then
stealing your balloons gotta be away
nope nope oh [ __ ] okay
so gotta be a little more cautious about
a lot of people who play this level but
there's got them then that means that
there's a good good basis of players who
have been through this hell goddamn it a
little too much I'm trying to get a
running start er like pause before I go
to each next one because that's gonna
get me low enough that I don't hit them
oh [ __ ] why did I go right off the bat I
was so eager to death so eager to get
embraced death key it's okay
everything's fine don't worry about it I
got this under control
this one I got whoa whoa hey buddy
friend okay this one hop sassafras
I gotta wait just like a little bit
longer on that chica what do you have
you have one of my socks take a leave it
leave it
oh god got [ __ ] knotted chica what
have you done she could leave it leave
it
hey leave it wrong good good job she's
smart she's getting smart she's not
she's not incredibly smart I don't wanna
give her too much benefit but she's good
enough I had an opportunity there I
hesitated midair I just went back a
little bit that's okay chica I still
love you just don't eat my socks hop hop
no get out of the way get out the way
get out of the way get out the way new
record yeah someone say there's a worth
level ever [ __ ] I got that on lock
now let's embarrass myself in the next
episode right chica good Eddie good very
good I'm just gonna try this a couple
times Bowser's and Castle that doesn't
sound good
at least they're giving me things I was
liking when I get things
well you're not it what that man but I
trusted so hard for me to trust again
goddamnit it was gonna give me a thing
it might be a good thing I see one pixel
red that seems like a good thing alright
I got this it's okay chica I love you I
love you lots
okay dad
freak damn it you freak he's down of a
fridge okay it's rise again with less
sock I've got a dubious amounts of suck
okay what hello well god damn it oh I
don't know how I made it
can I get Josh thank you yes I needed
this from it toughen things stuffing
things okay can you please thank you oh
god I am off I shouldn't have taken so
many shrooms man oh no one's ever made
that joke Oh even had an arrow where I
was supposed to be going that's awfully
convenient of it I didn't think that it
was gonna be nice to me okay I've got
even more stuffs gonna do some I heard
you go that way you dick hop okay here
we go
goodbye well that's not what I was
looking for wookie alright goodbye then
okay oh that was those clutch
ah [ __ ] this one I believe you I'm
trusting you it was right the last time
why but they mess with me hello can I
have this
okay I'm just gonna leave that there
okay everything's fine
chica what are you doing you crazy pop
she's rubbing her face all over
everything okay I'm gonna pick this up
in the next video I'm all that time for
this one so thank you everybody so much
for watching
cheer me on in the comments because I'm
gonna do it this time with women
it's gonna go better for me thanks again
and as always I'll see you